hey guys and welcome back to The Layah Heilpern
Show we are quite a few episodes in now so i'm
really excited we have a really cool guest
today but before we do want to say a quick
thank you and a quick shout out so this is
powered by icon um iconplus are i'm super
excited to announce that it will be integrated
into orbit bridge developed by orbit chain
bringing many ethereum assets to the icon project
and bridging top blockchains including icon
clayton ethereum and terra i also want to say a
quick thank you to my sponsors blockfi so i use
them i an update 8.6 interest on my usdc and an
announcement actually came out today about the
bank of england they're offering i think it's 0.01
interest so if 8.6 percent interest sounds great
to you and then i'll leave the link below you can
get 250 when you sign up and before i bring on my
really exciting guest um another quick shout out
to coinflip so they're doing some incredible work
across the states to push bitcoin mass adoption
they now have 1 200 bitcoin atms um so i'm going
to leave a code below as well you can get 10 off
that so joining me today is crypto trader advisor
xdj and music producer it is scott melker how
are you doing i'm great how are you thank you
so much for for having me on yeah it's great to
have you i've seen all you know i'm watching your
tweets and watching your content and it's
good just to speak to the person directly
it's been pretty crazy um you
know the last couple of days and
i will talk about bitcoin um but i kind of
want to learn a little bit more about you
understand wolf of all streets where that came
from um but i want to go back to the music because
you were a music producer and a dj so what
happened why are you not doing that anymore
i age you know i i just kind of uh aged out to be
honest i don't know if you've ever seen the movie
dazed and confused but matthew mcconaughey he has
a famous character and a famous line in that movie
and he says talk about high school girls and
he says i get older they stay the same age well
that's how i felt about djing i kept getting older
but the people i was djing to never got any older
right and so at one point i was like in my mid
to late 30s my wife was at home with my daughter
and i was out traveling and playing shows at like
fraternity houses and like 20 year old kids were
trying to get me drunk and all i wanted to do was
go home and face time with my daughter and it's
just you know kind of a unsustainable there are
people who can do it um and listen there's amazing
djs who are in their 60s 50s 60s who have been
doing it but that's a very select group that sort
of i think live for that lifestyle so partially it
was i guess uh choice and partially i mean i just
slowly became less passionate about it and and
less relevant i mean to be to be quite honest
like if you're not passionate about it at that
age there's always a 20 year old killer dj who's
like coming to take the title you know what i mean
so um and it coincided very well with my sort of
discovery of crypto i was already trading and love
trading and so i just it's kind of my nature to
become extremely focused on singular things
which is weird i have adhd but that can
sometimes manifest in hyper focus on certain
things um and ignoring everything else and that
became crypto for me it just sort of went from
there yeah that's cool i mean i like to hear
um you know some people talk about adhd like
it's a bit of a nightmare when it comes to
you know just getting on and stuff but that's
really cool to hear you know it made you focus
on one thing i guess priorities just change don't
they yeah it's just life you know like yeah i i
um everybody always kind of thought i was nuts
in all of my life decisions throughout you know
i went to an ivy league university and then passed
on wall street to dj and i started like four
failed or moderately successful companies during
that time it was always some crazy whimsical idea
i don't know i just you know my priorities sort
of shift with the wind or like i said with what
i'm feeling particularly passionate about at
a time but there does come a certain age where
um well it's not even age it's having kids
and having a family like you can't really
focus purely on yourself i was very selfish
you know in my pursuits and everything
that was a very big struggle to to get there
mentally but once you have kids and you see how
important it is to spend time with them everything
changes i mean everything you makes okay so family
is obviously huge for you i think that's one
of the most adorable things on your feed to
be honest i'm always seeing your kids and you
know your relationship with your wife on twitter
um twitter is full of trolls and crypto twitter
particularly um you know it can be quite dangerous
right so i'm just interested how come you're
comfortable putting your family uh i mean i
guess your wife's already on twitter but like
you're showing your kids because a lot of people
don't even put their names out there you know
i get that question all the time so one is that
i was doing it before i was involved in crypto so
to be to some degree there was no putting the cap
back in the bag like i uh i never was pursuing a
career in crypto as a influencer or whatever like
i was just a dude with some followers for music
who started talking about crypto right and so for
whatever reason it built but it was never like a
business decision ever so i just always sort of
behaved as i always did um and i believe and it's
not to begrudge anyone who is anonymous because i
am jealous of them at times i wish that i
could just go about my life in that manner
and it is dangerous as you said like some of
the stories i could share are pretty nuts um
hacks and threats and things like that but at the
end of the day like i feel like somebody has to
do it like some and i'm not saying like i'm some
great example or anything but somebody has to be
out there showing what real life looks like um
and so yeah like i over share i get a lot of uh
comments on that i don't think i'm putting
my children in danger if in danger if i legit
legitimately did i wouldn't do it but i i
was a public figure to some degree before
and i always have been so like there's no hiding
my personal information anymore you know it's just
it's it's not going to happen so there are a lot
of advantages to being docs and being yourself as
you know right i mean you probably wouldn't have
icon block fi and coin flip listed on the bottom
of this if you were a uh cartoon unicorn you know
uh yeah and as this space grows um there will be
you know more tremendous opportunities i think for
people who are showing their faces and whatever
the i think the irony of the whole thing is
because i show my face i get called a fake
more often than people who don't i know it's so
funny isn't it yeah i mean yeah like you you make
some interesting points i think i'm actually i can
totally relate because i was online before crypto
um you know especially because i'm a millennial
so i'm in my 20s so you know i guess growing up
as a teenager like there are pictures of me as
a baby in my dad's arms on myspace so no one go
look for that um don't do that but yeah there
are pictures there and i guess you can't really
you can't really do much about it at that point
but i think you're right you know when you say
somebody has to do it like how is this thing going
to go mainstream if we're all just hiding behind
avatars you know for you to for somebody to rely
and like trust in something there needs to be a
level of accountability and you don't have that
if we're all anonymous yeah and listen when i was
younger a i was a bit of a troll myself um just
in the dj community it was very similar like a lot
of competition that guy sucks that guy's not even
djing he's fake like all that you know it kind of
echoed the same thing and i was definitely like
a loud mouth sort of there i was less mature um
but like so i'm kind of the trolling thing
doesn't bother me i actually like every time
somebody tries to troll me i like giggle on the
inside and i share it with my friends i'm sure
you've seen me reading my dms you know like i just
thought that was so good because like i just need
to do that i mean these people don't know me
you know what i mean like that and i'm i feel
like i'm being transparent but like haters are
gonna hate you know and it's fine and and if it
sort of propels helps propel the space forward
doing my small part i'm more than happy to like
take the abuse of a few uh cartoons you know but
like you said it does it does sometimes verge on
uncomfortable territory like sim swappings and
being targeted for hacks and i've had people you
know send me personal photos they shouldn't
have had of yeah in my own town so like as
if they were like watching us you know things
like that so wow that's all very strange but um
you know yeah that's pretty yeah that's pretty
insane i mean you're obviously much bigger than
i am i've not experienced that the only thing
i experienced it wasn't which wasn't off it was
just kind of like a weird thing i was in romania
um and i was walking and um some guy just comes
straight up to me he's like you're layer and
i'm like oh yeah yeah that's just cool yeah
yeah that's just cool though i think it's nice
yeah yeah it was good i don't know how either i
had like no makeup on and my glasses on so i was
just like oh clearly i look the same thank you
yeah exactly flattered without my pokers literally
um but you tweeted yesterday which i thought was
really interesting that this year has changed
your opinion on a lot from like politics to money
um tell me about that i'm so fascinated
by that um yeah i think that uh
a lifetime of experience sort of implants ideas in
your head right you start um as a child and all of
your core beliefs or the beliefs of your parents
or your community or whatever you're immediately
surrounded with right see it religion nationalism
all these things if if like i was raised jewish
right and but if i had been born in iran and i was
raised my whole life view would be different and
of no doing of my own right just where
i landed and what i was surrounded by
so you know then you kind of grow up you go to
college you get like maybe more exposure another
life view and then through life i think you just
sort of evolve and even in my 20s and 30s i think
i was very stuck in like sort of value systems
that i just assumed were right or whatever and
i think you really start thinking for yourself
in your 30s and then you start to get you know
yourself in your 40s and then you totally know
yourself apparently according to oprah in your 50s
i even tweeted yesterday maybe yesterday i was
like you know basically anything you think you
probably believe in your 20s you'll like shake
your head at in your 40s like my 20 year old
self would troll my 40 year old self and my 40
year old self would go choke my 20 year old self
you know what i mean um but this year has been a
great accelerator for a lot of things obviously
we're all in the bitcoin space we all understand
that but like i understood that fiat was a scam
obviously you know i'm into bitcoin but seeing how
the world and central banks and monetary policy
was crafted after covid started if you couldn't
change your opinion fundamentally like even if
you had some hope or you figured hey i have some
trust in the system like my government will take
care of me please right so um and so 2020 was
interesting i think in that regard but then we
also had the election right with like probably
the most polarizing president or a candidate
in history regardless of your feelings on him as a
candidate or as a as a person like i have a lot of
stories like i went to school with trump jr i've i
they're one of the first one of the first times i
went viral unfortunately was because of that a
story i shared about them at the last election
i don't if you think i had to hide from people on
crypto twitter you should have seen me hiding from
trump supporters in uh in 2016. um but um but you
know that if you hate one candidate sort of pushes
you towards the other but then one day i think you
take the red pill and realize [ __ ] them all um
and that's sort of sorry i don't know if i can
say that in the show but um and that's sort of
that was sort of 2020 for me you know um i grew
up you know as a democrat like i was you know
my parents marched on washington and went to
woodstock and were hippies but then they became
you know more moderate as they aged like
anyone else there's that famous quote uh
if you're in your 20s like if you're not liberal
you have no heart if you're in your 40s and you're
not concerned maybe you have no brain right
so but now i think you find yourself in the
middle and then eventually you just quit
altogether and i i think i'm kind of sort
of at the ladder you know i view bitcoin and
what we're doing as a way to opt out i view it
as true freedom and i i don't think that um any
of these people can represent me or my beliefs
yeah i mean you make so many points there you
know in terms of like okay so your parents
were democrats yes if you don't have if you if if
you're not a democrat when you're young you don't
have a heart if you the other way you don't have
a brain right but i mean like things have become
far more polarized anyway so i imagine you know
even if they kept their views you probably find
that a lot more moderate and center anyway just
because things have become absolutely normal like
i i still make the argument that probably 90 i'm
only speaking for the united states but probably
true everywhere i believe that 90 okay called 80
of the people here are just middle of the road and
if they actually sat down to think about their
beliefs they would find their middle of the road
but most of them are just in this sort of like
zombie like mass media state of believing whatever
you know the news station they watch has been
pounding into their brain indefinitely over time
you know um i think most people don't really think
for themselves but once they do i think you'll
find that hey some of the stuff those guys say
is really true and some of the stuff these guys
say is really true and i have my mixed basket
of beliefs and emotions and i'm me right and
i don't have to be either of them but i will say
one other thing that was huge in 2020 because of
the fiscal policy and the monetary policy and the
way that we've seen now both parties react is that
there is no more fiscal responsibility in
government on either side you know like
republicans used to claim they were the fiscal
fiscally responsible party that was reagan you
know like reagan and bush but then clinton
balanced the budget right but then since then
it's been money printing money printing has no
party money printing has no politics and money
printing is what's destroying people's lives
forget all the like things that they're all
the wagging the dog and all the distractions all
things you're looking at at the core of it all
is the fact that you're not making more money
and your money's worth less and that's what's
destroying people's lives yeah you make an
insane point on that you're gonna touch on that
it's exactly the same in the uk so we have the
conservative party in right now and we're all just
like can you bring back the conservative party
like i feel like we have a left-wing government in
right just because naturally those are kind of the
socialist policies that you'd imagine seeing not
necessarily money printing but yeah you follow me
um so that's exactly what we're saying what we're
seeing here and i'm also feeling really apolitical
um so in terms of bitcoin then what was it that
kind of what was that orange pill like orange
peel red pill moment that got you into it was it
the underlying because i know that we say it's
apolitical but in my opinion i often find it
kind of is political just because it's all about
like being left alone right and that tends to be a
libertarian um i don't say right wing because
that also means something else these names are
all jumbled up but yeah for me it's political what
about you i think it's very fair to say that it's
political i just can't assign it to either party
and i think that's a important distinction so
like yes it's political absolutely but i think
it's sort of a way to rage against the machine
of politics itself right so to to be a political
in itself is political to some degree right
because you would prefer that there was a a party
or a politician who still represented you you just
can't find one that does and that's why you're
sort of a political right so that's one bitcoin
i came for the money not for the bitcoin like
i was trading you know what i mean and there's
this like mythical land of 100x all coin pumps
happening and my friends were getting into it
and telling me about it you know and i came for
that and i sort of like you know backed into i
guess the importance of actual bitcoin even until
last year and listen like i get trolled constantly
for like [ __ ] i used to say but guess what
i've changed my opinion i've changed my opinion
and i'm not deleting it you know like go back
and find it i'll i'll answer for it it's fine
but like even a year ago i was like aggressively
like five percent of your money maybe 10 if you're
crazy in crypto this is volatile like it
could whatever and this year it's like
i ain't rebalancing i'm riding this thing as
far as i can ride it because it's important so
i used to be in it to make dollars because i would
make the point i can't pay my kids private school
tuition and my mortgage now i want more bitcoin
like genuinely you know and so i think for me
the real big aha moment still happened this year i
think there were seeds of it last year and listen
if you were here in 16 or 17 which kind of when i
started like i really got into it in early 2017.
and you rode the bear market like with it and you
still had a passion for it then you certainly had
some belief in it but like now you're seeing all
the things that you were called crazy for actually
play out i talked to jamison lop i don't know if
you know him if you don't you should have him on
the show you know when the original cypherpunks
and whatever and that was what he said he's like
i don't even give a [ __ ] that the price has gone
up so crazy i'm just happy that nobody's calling
me crazy anymore and i can laugh at all these
people after 10 years you know and it's it really
there is some uh there is some like satisfaction i
guess in that yeah no absolutely i mean i'm seeing
like i told you so tweets um and all this stuff
but i think that's really interesting because
you've said you know you've been here since like
2016 2017 but it was really this year that just
sort of i guess kind of like brought everything
to a crescendo and you were really able to sort of
see that value that true yeah yeah i think i just
got really so disgusted with everything this year
yeah the great answer for being disgusted
with everything it really is yeah so this
is an interesting topic which i want to get into
um because people look at bitcoin as this like
you said when you don't have a party and you're a
political you go to bitcoin and you sort of feel
like you know it's all about freedom and
independence and um personal responsibility
and so on um but it's interesting so i
had rao powell on the show the other day
and he his opinion is that this freedom
um obviously i hope i've interpreted this
correctly but why from what i understood he was
sort of saying that it's all a narrative and
this idea of freedom and you know where we're
independent and with this and with that and
privacy he sort of said it's just a narrative and
it's not true it's something that maybe maybe you
could call it propaganda or whatever it is
but it's something that we're playing into
and regulation's inevitable and that we will never
have this kind of like um you know utopia this
this utopia whereby you know we're all free and
you know we're exchanging peer-to-peer and where
did you sort of think that we're
actually going to get to this perfect
future no i mean i i i think i am somewhere in the
middle of that i mean i agree with the sentiment
of what he's saying but that doesn't diminish
the importance of what we're doing right um
and it's it's a catch-22 because like if you want
your bitcoin to rise you need other people that
don't know about bitcoin yet to want to buy it
right so like if all these people were talking
about getting like filthy rich on bitcoin you need
all those things to happen regulation is obviously
coming um i don't necessarily think that's a
bad thing i don't think bitcoin can be banned
by any stretch but like they can certainly make it
really really difficult to uh to get your money in
and out you know i think that's the the fear of
regulation that would be worth having but i mean
at the end of the day it's still the best shot
that we have um no i don't think and also like i
think the bitcoin sort of peer-to-peer narrative
has somewhat died i know that that's the white
paper you know peer-to-peer cash i think that
it's been solidified as you know store of value uh
gold 2.0 and to be quite honest with you i think
a stable coin is a better peer-to-peer cash than
is it sends faster you get the same amount that
you see the person receiving it gets the same
amount of money that you sent you know i don't
know if that's a hot take or controversial but
i think that people want to hold their bitcoin
now and that's better that's that's what it's for
yeah it shouldn't be a hot take should it um but
but it is because people are sort of like well
stable coins enable the fiat system you know it
enables it but no i'm totally with you you know
you i mean even even in terms of like earning
passive income you know you get great interest
on your stable coins it just i think it it it's
all personal it all depends on what you want um
i definitely see bitcoin as more of a store
of value i'm totally with you on that so but
unfortunately it is controversial right but you
know as he's saying it's a part of it will become
a part of the system it'll become regulated but if
you have a true true deep belief in bitcoin like
you always have that possibility
in your mind that the system fails
yes right so if the entire system fails bitcoin
will become that crazy you know you well dystopian
not utopian but thing that sort of people talk
about so i think like i said i think it's both
like they can regulate it to death they can do all
these things they can turn it into wall street but
if wall street fails and if central banks fail
and if we see hyperinflation bitcoin will return
to that thing that we're talking about so i think
it's a bit of both right now the world's not
as much as the world looks like a like a like it's
collapsing it's not the dollar is not collapsing
it's dropping but we're not seeing hyperinflation
all those things so in the context of the
existing environment now i think he's correct
yeah absolutely i think that's just a narrative
you know um like like you said even no matter even
if everything does fail the technology is still
there if we end up in a situation like venezuela
there have been issues in nigeria um you know
if we end up in that kind of situation then we
have bitcoin and we still have the technology um
but you you are a trader so i want to know because
i actually don't trade um i mean not not in the
way that you do um but what are the key things you
look out for in a good trade so like i always sort
of go out there and say that trading is basically
gambling really can be really fun it can be really
profitable but um just to be clear like
i'm an investor first even though i trade
quote-unquote professionally i still will only
trade with 15 of my capital like sometimes if
the market's really good i'll go up but i'm
generally at least 50 in long-term investments
15 in cash and like 15 percent um excuse me 70
investment 15 cash 15 trading so even though
i'm a trader trader like i don't i'm not dumb
enough to do it with all of my money you know
um and then and historically probably my
investments have done better than my trades
you know so that's kind of you know just uh to to
be clear there what i'm looking for like the way i
approach trading i love charts i love technical
analysis but i have no fallacy that it predicts
the future or any sort of science right i view
technical analysis as a risk management tool
just a way for me to justify in my own mind
where i want to buy something where my idea
is invalidated so where to put my stop loss and
where i want to sell it to take profit so you
can do that in a million ways right you can like i
don't know sacrifice baby kittens if it gives you
like the right entry it doesn't matter or you
can use elliott waves or rsi it doesn't matter
right so i believe in charts as a risk management
tool but at the end of the day all that matters in
trading is being able to control your emotions and
actually play out your plan without changing it in
the middle like you have to let your stop-loss
hit like that if you're if you have to let your
stop-loss hit and you have to actually sell when
you're in profit and not get greedy and think
it's going to go higher and that's all trading is
and almost nobody can do it i was terrible at it
do you take um fundamentals into account um when
you're trading i do now um and i always did like
with stocks since like when you trade a stock you
buy a stock because you think it's a good company
right so like that's why crypto was always so
fun because it was like this crazy no fundamental
world where you could just like look at these
charts and trade and things would go and made
you feel like this genius but in reality you're
probably just there um but um now i think that
the market has somewhat changed so i like take
less trades and i make more sort of investments
there's all these you know opportunities i
guess because um i have a following or people
know me or whatever but pre-sale opportunities
and all these like new d5 projects and stuff
i'm aggressively sort of looking for opportunities
to invest in things really early and sort of
approach it that way although like i you know uh
and i think that that long term is more profitable
and that's fully fundamental right like if you
if you're getting in before there's even a chart
um or sort of the days that they launch so like
i think like my investor mode has gone like full
full meth head this year um and you know trading
has i do it a lot but like trading has taken
largely a back seat because we like it's not like
2017 where it was like full fomo like now i think
you can actually pay attention to the fundamentals
of projects and listen it's really hard to pay
attention to the fundamentals of old projects
that have bag holders that are down 90 but like
new stuff i think there's a lot of opportunities
to find ones that could really be like impactful
companies you don't have to answer this but i'm
just wondering is there anything which um sort of
looks interesting to you there are a lot of new
projects this year um particularly d5 projects
is there anything that you're looking out for in
2021 there are so many i like there are so many um
actually today i'm talking a friend of
mine benjamin minshew i don't know if
you're familiar with elrond or yeah yeah yeah
of course yeah about them like i love them and
i love him i had him on my podcast many months
ago and i just like believe in their project
so i'm really excited about what they have and
literally like i'm talking to him today again
been begging him to come back and chat with me
so um really passionate about them you trust
is a company i really really love yeah bitcoin is
utk um it's funny i do this what we're doing right
now like i have people on my podcast and then i
become like a super fanboy and i get really buying
their coins so that's you know i had sonia khan on
but i've been uh you know i have a newsletter and
utrust has been working on figuring out a way to
do recurring crypto payments which nobody's been
able to ever ever able to do so i've been working
with them for a long time and something like that
uh poco pulpa starter p-o-l-s is the coin is like
one i'm really excited about and they actually
their first idea was launched today mahadow like
there's just so many and like so many of them
are gonna go to complete [ __ ] like 99 not the
ones i'm mentioning i don't think but like yeah
but i i think that this time like we're seeing
the rug pulls and all that craziness and that
[ __ ] is really sad and unfortunate but most
of these people are very well intel well um
intentioned people with brilliant ideas and some
of them are just gonna be incredible and most
will just fail for whatever various reasons that
these projects fail but um if you're in a position
monetarily to like throw money at ten of them
and accept that like seven might go to crap but
three of them will make you rich then godspeed you
know do it i like it i like the mentality um yeah
i mean people always ask me where do you see this
thing going in ten years and i'm like well let's
say 90 of these projects won't be here anymore oh
i'm surprised it's i i thought we'd have seen it
already from a lot of stuff yeah i mean but
they're still congrats still hanging around
yeah trainers are driving most of that though yeah
that is true that is true i want to talk about
bitcoin because it is going crazy i think before
um we went live it was and there we go so it's at
23 500 which is pretty insane i want to get your
thoughts just generally um on this year bitcoin's
performance you know it dropped in march uh when
all the news came out but then it sort of just
snapped right back um ahead of everything so did
you expect that and yeah did you expect that i did
um and i have a long history of tweets to prove it
for anyone who says that i'm hindsight um whatever
so like i i don't believe that and maybe unfairly
like i've never particularly turned bearish on
bitcoin there have been times when i shorted
it like as a trader but you know in general uh
not at all so um march was scary yes um it was
scary and you know but uh and and so i was like
standing on top of the hill just taking shots
saying that bitcoin was an uncorrelated asset
and never sort of changed that narrative and when
it all dropped everybody obviously came after me
like ha ha how's your not correlation now and
you know i try to explain to people that in
those terrible moments for that one or two weeks
things are horrible and everything correlates and
drops but we've seen now what bitcoin has done
relative to everything else so hopefully i found
some vindication um in that but yes i did expect
it to come back so for for two two reasons first
of all i think we had a the beginning of that drop
in march uh was uh flight to flight to liquidity
right so you had like bigger players that had
tried to get exposure you couldn't sell a bond
right literally there was nobody there to sell to
buy your bonds which is insane so bigger players
had to sell bitcoin because liquid you can
literally get your cash out of bitcoin anytime
any moment which is a good thing but bad at that
moment and then you know that may be sent it from
9000 to 7500 on march 12th and then there's
no question that bitx destroyed the market
that day their liquidation engine just started
firing like liquidations of 15 20 30 million
dollar shorts into a mark and there was no orders
to buy them so price went all the way down to you
know 3800 they turned it off or they would have
literally sent it to zero there was a point on
their books where there was like only 15 million
dollars left from zero to 3 800 in buy orders
right so and that's why we saw it snap right back
to 6 000 like 12 hours later so like i i view the
back half of that entire move as just the wild
west yolo casino that is bitcoin right and not
something that really was like fundamental and
we've risen steadily from there you know and
there there was never a doubt in my mind that
we were on our way back i never thought we'd go
to 1000 or 2000 and frankly like i even wrote
about this literally today my newsletter like
there's a very big difference between the value
of something and the price of something okay um
and bitcoin especially right i mean if the
value is is really the fundamentally what
something is worth and the price is what someone's
willing to pay for it at any given moment right
holders held through all of that they didn't give
a [ __ ] like they knew that it would rise again
and we're seeing the fundamental value of
bitcoin as a hedge against inflation as a
store of value all these things and that has not
been reflected in the price most of this year
and now price is catching up to the value in
my opinion and you know that that value is real
when you see microstrategy and john and stanley
druckenmiller and and paul tudor jones and every
billionaire on the planet now talking the book
and saying that uh they're they're coming in
and that [ __ ] does not happen randomly they
don't buy an asset that does not have value
and they're not buying it to sell it a thousand
dollars higher right and that so people and
they're also not buying it if they have any
legitimate fear until that the government is going
to ruin that for them you don't think michael
saylor has a friend at the sec who he calls before
he buys a billion dollars worth of bitcoin give me
a break right damn when you put it like that scott
these guys are not buying something that's going
to be regulated to zero it's just not happening
they like goldman's like these jp morgan these
guys they are the treasury right i mean like it's
it's a revolving door between goldman sachs and
jp morgan and the government and so you know i
think that the value of bitcoin is much higher
i think that these companies that want it as a
treasury asset that believe that they need to
have exposure to protect their cash like it's
not even big enough or the price isn't high enough
yet for them to buy apple can't put a half percent
of their treasury in bitcoin without buying every
bitcoin on the planet right so like the market cap
needs to be in the trillions like gold and they
will yeah no i think it's insane um you mentioned
it was scary someone just wrote in the comments
which i think is really funny well it's not funny
but i'm happy for him now so someone writes lol
in march i saw my life savings dropped 50 percent
but i just kept hodling and buying more good for
you kevin that's conviction and that works as
long as you know listen isn't it like if you're
an investor that you have belief in something
yeah you shouldn't even be checking the value of
it yes you know every day like it should be like
your long-term investment portfolio should have a
30-40 year timeline and horizon and you should be
looking at it every six months to see if you need
to like slightly tweak something i mean i used to
so like i used to buy spy which is you know like
spx basically like i still do um monthly you know
just dollar cost averaging it's basically the
best way to just track the stock market and i
started doing this in like 2006 or 2007 when i
finally had like a little money and i could do it
and like immediately we hit this crazy recession
like global recession and it dropped you know 50
60 whatever it was and like it was just going in
the background i never thought about it and then
like by 2020 like literally every single purchase
of spy i'd ever done since 2006 was in profit
you know and and if you have a long time horizon
like he's talking about like you're buying those
dips that's what you want to do i i talked to
peter brandt the other day actually you know
the famous trader and he said to me he's like i
tell my kids that you should buy a company that
you like and hope the price goes down 50 so you
can buy more yeah yeah that's conviction um that's
absolutely conviction like my my brother i was
talking to him about bitcoin today because i told
him to buy at 10k and he was like no no i'm gonna
wait till he gets a bit under i was like it's not
going under um and you know he's asking me now
um oh are you going to sell he's like you know
you should sell and i'm like no because what's
the point like i i think it's going to go higher
like i think 100k i don't know when but you know
i think 100k i think 400k i i i think gold 2.0 um
so there's yeah so you know it's so funny it's
like 23k and my brother's like why don't you sell
and i'm like no it doesn't make sense so we've
hit new highs we're in price discovery mode um
tell me what do you think is going to go what's
going to happen i mean a lot of people are talking
i've had 100k by quarter one or 2021. i don't know
how i feel about that um what do you think nothing
makes you look like a jackass more than a wild
price prediction that doesn't come true so i try
very hard not okay because sort of no but sort
of like you're saying you're not selling it so
why does it matter right like i don't care i mean
i i don't want the price to go down i don't want
to have six thousand dollar video weekend anytime
dude that would be uh really bad but um i think
those numbers are in play that's all i'm saying
like i don't know what the timeline is for that to
happen or when it would happen but um i'd be very
i mean you know it was what 3 800 i mean we're up
six seven times already since march like just
double it doubling from here is almost 50 grand
and percentages percentage moves matter much more
than the fixed number right that's why like most
traders use logarithmic charts because a 25 000
move uh even let's say a one thousand dollar
move from nineteen thousand to twenty thousand
is nothing compared to a one thousand dollar
move from two thousand to three thousand right
that's a fifty percent move so you get caught
up in now these numbers but the bigger numbers
make sense in the context of percentage growth
and that's what you're concerned so even a 2x from
here puts us near 50 000 i'd be very surprised if
we didn't do a 2x from here at some point the next
year or two but i think the higher targets are in
play like i don't think 300 400 are insane and i
will be pretty disappointed if we don't hit 100
at some point yeah of course when do you think the
foam is gonna absolutely come piling in i say 50k
oh yeah i think like 40 50. i think it's starting
i'm definitely getting the like and i just like
it's just so funny like i told people like i
couldn't have screamed louder like bitcoins
six thousand dollars buy it just buy it just buy
some and now the same people who didn't want it
now are asking me if they should buy it at twenty
three thousand dollars i know do you know what
really frustrates me um it's kind of like so i'm
just like here head down working in the crypto
space like really just like doing it you know i
guess like you know your career is gambling on it
um you know my friends are off doing like pr
and medicine and law and whatever they're doing
um and then i get the call leia so like you
know how how do i buy bitcoin and i'm like oh
yeah like you don't it's like you you know you
need it you need them to like come in eventually
but also like those are they start to be top
signals you know so like you just it's like
such a catch 22. like stay out of here but also we
kind of need you like somebody has to somebody's
gonna have to whenever the top is somebody's
gonna have to buy it right so yeah i want to
get your thoughts on ethereum um so i think that
touch was it 700 yesterday or just just under 700
um not really watching a theorem that much right
now but probably should um what are your thoughts
do you think that's going to get to um 1k before
bitcoin gets to 25. what are your thoughts i mean
that would be a really bad bet as a gambler just
because that's like almost a 50 move for ethereum
and it's like a couple percent from here for for
bitcoin so no i mean even if i thought that like
if i was a gambling man and you gave me odds
i would take uh bitcoin hitting 25 first but
i think ethereum's gonna perform better than
bitcoin oh really in the long run or just in
2021 in the coming months and years i think that
uh even rationally um you know bitcoin's past its
all-time high and ethereum's at half it's all-time
high so even if it just reaches an all-time high
it's 100 you know it's a doubling move um and so
i would see that happening uh largely the d5 boom
is happening on ethereum whether that means
ethereum itself has to go up or not but like
ethereum is being used literally every single day
like if you've ever been on uniswap or something
and paid gas fees then you definitely know like
ethereum is being used people need it so there's a
legitimate demand for it also like we're starting
to see sort of the same hints of what we saw with
bitcoin earlier this year okay with institutions
with ethereum like we hear everyone talking about
bitcoin but then all of a sudden like grayscale
last week was like well we're getting a lot more
calls about ethereum than we are about bitcoin
and our ethereum trust and and greyscale is like
not only have they bought all the bitcoin that's
been mined and more they've bought more ethereum
than it's been mined and more you know and
that shows that there's real institutional and
serious demand and i'm trying to think who
it was today guggenheim okay um you know said
that they want to buy a couple hundred million
and they said in bitcoin and ethereum evenly
so like i think that and i think that rationally
the same sort of fomo we're talking about there's
people who like feel like they missed bitcoin
who maybe won't feel like they missed ethereum
and can get it quote unquote cheaper you know
so i think that there's a lot of things that
line up for ethereum to do very well and you
know and ethereum 2.1 has been successful
you know they've managed they managed to well
overshoot the amount they needed staked i just
think there's a lot of bullishness and i don't
think you have to like choose one or the other
i think it's fine to like both i don't view
ethereum as a store of value ethereum is digital
gold i view it as a great platform that that
has a chance to grow and and appreciate and so
it's like that whole like hatred of the two
communities is so weird to me it's like can you
imagine like all the people who love tesla just
being super pissed at everyone who likes amazon
yeah i mean so okay two things here so firstly
the ceo of old coinbase once said to me so his
name's shash i think he's amazing he once said to
me that um ethereum is the amazon it is amazon and
bitcoin is gold and i just love that
comparison i thought it was amazing
um that's even better yeah yeah i think it's great
okay so like tribalism right there's like huge
inner space and i think i tweeted a few months ago
something like imagine not liking somebody because
they prefer a different coin to you and holy [ __
] like that blew up and you know i had adam back
in the comments writing stuff calling things like
ethereum a scam um i think maybe he called cosmos
a scam um and ponzi schemes or whatever so why do
people just like really hate on ethereum you know
we're having a really normal conversation right
now why are we not able to do this why why is
it bitcoin only why can't ethereum you know be
something different in its own in its own right
i don't know um well no i mean i i i it's a
symptom of a larger problem like in life and we've
talked about it already a bit like people are just
try tribalism is the norm right it's like my team
my country my religion my town my my you know
whatever it is like people just they like to like
root for theirs and there's people who are very
early on bitcoin and i don't know if they see it
as a threat or they just view like everything
else as a distraction or what it is but like
to outwardly call something that's successful and
has positive elements like a scam or something
it's just i mean it's just it doesn't make sense
and to me that's like uh it's like showing your
hand that you're like an overly emotional just
sort of like yeah disheveled human person you
know um like why do you care even if you like
really don't like it maybe just like ignore it
like just stuff that i really like don't
like or agree with i generally just ignore
like i don't spend my my energy on negativity
towards something that doesn't affect my life
and i think that like
there's it's just really like
it's really crazy and the and the and the [ __ ]
up thing is that like if everybody just stopped
doing that like they would all get so much richer
like because if everybody just worked together and
was like generally positive about crypto as a
whole we're way too small to be like fighting
amongst ourselves you know so if everybody who had
a passion for any project or crypto or whatever
was just sort of like you know a rising tide
lifts all boats and said hey if ethereum does
great today that's awesome because it brings more
attention and you know my link will eventually
rise or whatever it is i think that we would get
where we're looking to go so much so much faster
because people are just really emotional
and they're just like it's a it's a it's a
matter of being right and wrong and
which doesn't really matter right
yeah i i think it's an interesting one um i
think um you know if you say something like
that you know you say something like we should
um call these things out because they're scams
and i i wholeheartedly believe they're scams and
i think that's immoral um you know if the it's
kind of like a social justice warrior kind of
thing because it's like well hang on you're not
following through if you're such a moral person
and you want to protect people there are a lot
of you know far more um awful injustices going
on in the world so like you could focus on that
you know if it was if it really came from such
a pure and moral place you know which is like i
don't want to get if i don't get too much into
politics but that's kind of like the situation
in politics with social justice warriors are like
talking about like microaggressions and all this
stuff when you have like actual genocide
going on which they're not interested in
in talking about which kind of i don't know some
synergies i guess um yeah yeah i mean yeah i mean
if you ever needed an example of that which kind
of like when we're talking about like changing
your politics or whatever like everybody
stay inside but it's totally cool to write
come on right i mean so we see
examples of that kind of thing
um all the time and i agree
with you i think it's just like
it's not their real feeling it's just like a
emotional reaction to something that they've
it's just being triggered like why does ethereum
trigger you if you like bitcoin like why mm-hmm
no i wouldn't do it with you it's funny um i have
a few interesting topics i want to go through um
still before before we head to the end one
which i want to touch on is ross um albrecht
i don't know how to pronounce his name properly
exactly yeah for us yeah so let's talk about that
because you know trump has come to the end of his
presidency people say you know he he's pardoning
um he's pardoned some people are ready um he
said he's not going to pardon edward snowden um
he sort of went hard on that i was like no he
did this he did that what are your thoughts
um on free ross i know a lot of people in the
community aren't actually all forfeiting ross
i'm i'm all for free and ross yeah um i had a
long talk with his mom so maybe i'm like biased
because she's like the sweetest woman in the world
and just like wants clemency for her son but um
first of all even if ross was guilty of every
single thing that they say he's guilty of
he got two life sentences plus like 40 years
right uh like el chapo didn't even like get
a full life sentence or something like literal
and what's crazy is that the people like a
silk road 2 was started by people who were like
legitimate criminals and drug dealers and stuff
and got busted and got like short sentences
so like just the disproportionate punishment
so like i think ross probably should have gone
to jail yeah maybe like i don't you know i don't
know the ins and outs i don't believe he was
hiring hitmen to kill people and all that kind of
stuff but like you know i think he had he was very
idealistic like believed in libertarian things and
tried to do something good but maybe he broke
the law some doing it and maybe deserved to
go to jail for a while it's enough like two and a
half life sentences for uh letting some people buy
weed on the internet it's just absurd and you know
like there's just these times when one person is
becomes the example for whatever
reason he took a fall for like
yes the entire like the entire system the entire
entire space whatever and like it's enough like or
tell the guy he has to stay for five more years
and then let him out you know what i mean i
don't know what the just punishment is but i know
that it's not too lifetime he didn't kill anyone
and they can't even prove that anyone like
was hurt or died from anything that he allowed
you know and a lot of things that they say were
it was just drugs you know and like whatever
it's not like people were selling children and
and weapons of mass destruction all the things
that people rumored that was happening that's not
what was happening so i think yeah absolutely i
think it would be an amazing move by trump to
free him and if he doesn't i hope biden does
to be honest you know it's really funny i don't
think biden could care less um that's just my
opinion on biden i think he's you know without
getting too into but i think he's an absolute fake
um i don't think he's uh i think he's a bit of a
fake to be honest but i think you make a really
interesting point um you know as a libertarian
myself i'm still very much like i'm living in
a civil society follow the laws of the land um
but absolutely you know two life sentences plus
whatever you know i think rape people that
actually rape you know rape charges are less
than that um and in my opinion that's one of the
worst things charges are sometimes a slap on the
slap on the wrist and like uh listed on a website
or something you know what i mean like there are
people just doing far far worse things so yeah
like you said to me it's the disproportionate
punishment that does not fit the crime that is
really the biggest problem like i i can't really
not a legal scholar like i don't know the level
to which he committed a crime or not i've never
dug in but i know that whatever crime he
committed doesn't deserve the punishment
yeah and i think you make an interesting point as
well that it i think they were setting an example
of him yeah they said yeah they did because
something was they knew something was brewing
something brewed you know bitcoin is
here um and you know setting an example
um but if he started it like now he wouldn't
have even gotten in so much trouble there's also
absolutely the world just wasn't ready for
it it's sad yeah absolutely and speaking of
the world being ready for things i want to get
your thoughts um just as you come to the end of
this on mass adoption um you know what what
are we missing when it when will it happen
you know we talk a lot about user experience
but i'm hearing other things in terms of like
regulation and taxes and kind of just like
the logistics um being difficult yeah it's
hard because it depends on how you like define
mainstream adoption there's people who are like
bitcoin becomes the global currency and it's
the only thing we transact in well if that's
what you're waiting for we never get mainstream
adoption right because i don't think that that's
going to happen but if by mainstream adoption
we mean a asset that's respected and viewed like
any other asset that can be traded legally with
protections i think that's here like we're within
months i think more than months of what maybe
you'd call mainstream adoption um you know like
to me almost at this point when you're looking
at mainstream adoption would be like more people
using usdc than paypal to send their money you
know or like like things like that that um have
not happened yet and maybe will but like i don't
think it's going to replace the whole system
but i think that it can be normalized within the
system and still have its importance to those of
us who are like really passionate about it in
the community and to me that would be enough
mainstream adoption but like when you have
billionaires putting it in you know buying it with
their cash reserve their company that's pretty
mainstream i i think you're trying to hear i think
we're kind of here i think that there's levels to
it but i think that we've started maybe maybe it's
fair to say that we're for the first time we're
scratching the surface of mainstream adoption
yes that i can i can definitely agree with you on
i want to get to the point where i work with a guy
in um brazil who um isn't in crypto but he
edits some videos for me found him through
twitter he's a great guy um but we've got to
pay him through paypal and it's really annoying
um and there's just no like his english isn't
amazing like there's no way i can sit down with
him over zoom and be like here's how you open up
a wallet like let me pay him a bit like no well
for i mean central bank digital currencies are an
inevitability so very soon whether you like it or
not everyone in the world pretty much is going to
learn to transact digitally through a wallet right
that might be two or three years away but um that
is inevitable well that's good and you think it'll
be the same thing do you think it'll be like done
the same way with the wallet and the address and
do you think it'd be done like that i think it'll
be more simplistic than that but i do think that
you will have like a wallet on your phone and you
will like tap whether a qr code or something else
to send and receive a digital transaction and once
we have that level of understanding i mean if you
go to china everybody knows how to do that right i
want to spread that around the world i think that
um you know that'll only be good for for bitcoin
and stuff because i like if i'm given the option
to pay with a digital dollar or with like some
crypto currency especially if it has privacy
aspects i'm certainly going to choose the latter
even though the first one is is easy so i i think
that what you're talking about is just a matter of
time but i really believe it's inevitable whether
it's with a stablecoin or some other digital
currency like also like you can't microtransact
across borders with any legacy system try
wiring like 20 bucks to somebody in africa
you'll pay 20 bucks on your end they'll pay 20
bucks and the 20 bucks might arrive seven months
later you know it's just that it can't be done so
especially for those lower end transactions crypto
really is the only answer i'm not saying that's
bitcoin bitcoin's kind of clunky for that but
yeah i'm taking with you i um i took a trip to
asia quite a few years ago i was in cambodia and
i remember the the cat he's not a cab driver
he was a truck driver he um we paid him 15
for the entire week and for him that was so
much money right so if we understand that
um if we understand you know what's minimum
wage or whatever what's normal in that country
um and let's say we were supposed to work with
he's gonna do some work with me across borders
i couldn't you know i wouldn't be able to
pay him whatever whatever the wage is over
there you know um so i i think it's i think
it's incredible that we're actually able to
put people on the financial map for me that
was actually my my like my um my red pill
moment not so much bitcoin it was more like
blockchain putting people on the financial map
um for me because i'm all about social good i love
a good social good uh project so yeah yeah so do i
hence why i leaned left as a kid right it was
all about like social justice and helping people
and stuff and i still believe in all those things
um but yeah i mean most of the world is unbanked
right even in a lot of uh even in a lot of
established countries um you know six or seven out
of ten people don't have a bank account or access
to banking and stuff and that's just stupid so
like the goal now shouldn't be to get those
people banked yeah it should be to to skip
use this to just skip it right like if you
go to like that i you know if you talk to any
american soldiers a friend of mine um andrew
who was the ceo of a company called roundly x
like he was in afghanistan you know in the
united states military and he was like we
couldn't get running water we couldn't get
electricity but there was a cell phone store
like in every village you know so like all you
need is a mobile tower and crypto is accessible
to everybody in the world right cheap phone
whatever and so like skip the at this point you
don't think about getting people banked you just
think about circumventing that system altogether
yeah i love it you know it just absolutely
skipping um financial revolutions really um
i i think it's incredible i love watching
it um but i want to thank you so much for
coming on before we say goodbye where can people
find you just promote yourself you've you know
okay you've got a newsletter just tell us
everything sure i'm the worst self-promoter in
the world that's what tanked my music career but
um you can find me on you can find me on twitter
at scottmelker s-c-o-t-t-m-e-l-k-e-r and you can
find the information for everything else there
i have a youtube channel which i've just pretty
much started in the last couple months and it's
been really really fun i just love talking [ __ ]
and live streaming um and trolling the people in
my comments um the newsletter you can find the
link to that it's on it's get review slash the
wolf dead and then my podcast which is also on
my youtube and you know spotify apple everywhere
else the the wolf of all streets podcast those are
the main things that i do that keep me extremely
busy but at the core of it of course is twitter
so if you find me at scott milker you'll
find a very quick uh breadcrumb trail to
everything else that i've got my hands in
sounds great scott thank you so much thank you
everyone for watching thank you to iconplus for
powering it blockfi and coinfip for sponsoring it
guys we'll see you next thursday 12 p.m est bye